[Music]
it's time for Barbie to discover the
real world no no no no no no watch me
I've started to get all these weirdo
feelings it's anxiety I have a tooth
you're gonna start getting sad and mushy
and complicated she's not dead she's
just having an existential crisis
what about Ken I'm just a dude
Ken isn't something we're worried about
what
Barbie you're malfunctioning find the
girl who's playing with you playing with
me
we're all being played with babe the
real world isn't what I thought it was
being human can be pretty uncomfortable
and isn't that marvelous wow you've
always believed in Barbie you've got
this
okay can I sit in the front
let's do this
is Barbie's dream house not Ken's dream
house
right as always
[Music]
[Applause]
do you can go back to your regular life
or know the truth about the universe the
first one you have to want to know
Barbie in the real world yes everything
is backwards here girls hate me who are
you oh and I keep getting arrested it
also just learned to cry first I got one
tear and then I got a whole bunch
hi Barbie hi Ken
so you can go back to your regular life
or you can know the truth about the
universe
the choice is now yours the first one no
we'll do a redo
[Music]
you're supposed to wanna know I don't
you have to want to know okay do it
again
[Music]
it's Barbie land are we going to get
small like doll size or are Barbie's
hours yes
basically everything that men do in your
world women do in ours
Barbie is a doctor and a lawyer and it's
so much more than that ah help me
discontinue
hi Barbie there are pens too there are
many Ken's go to the Ken's day
I don't know
two of your dogs have gotten loose
Barbie and Ken we look great hey you
guys got to pay for that
[Music]
I'm not used to that having anything in
it
[Music]